good morning believe nation today's
message is don't stop over to you Tyler
Perry my only idea my only focus was to
do my one play and I knew if I could get
that to work everything else would come
to pass there's so many people who go in
so many directions they this week
they're doing this the next week they're
doing that and next week they're doing
this and next week they're gonna be in
real estate the next week they open a
salon it those those kind of people are
all over the place and I usually try to
get them to focus focus on one thing one
area put all of your energy into
watering one area if you spread the
water across many many seeds you don't
have as much water for one seed so focus
on one thing make it your priority and
stick with it no matter what no matter
how many people told me no no matter how
many people lied to me no matter how
many times I put the show up and nobody
came that I remembered when I did my
very first show I worked my butt off and
saved $12,000 tax returns to making our
block money I saved it worked hard saved
it myself ready to 14th Street Playhouse
put that show up thought that 1,200
people would come over a weekend and 30
showed up and I knew every one of them
but I didn't stop that didn't deter me
that was in 1992-93 same thing happened
I acted in 94 95 96 97 up until 1998
same devastation nobody showing up in
the audience I'm still in one show a
year working with different promoters
trying to get the show up and nobody
showed up
but I didn't stop and my my what I say
to you now looking at me now Here I am a
human being there's no difference
between my humaneness and your eminence
the only thing is if you're trying to
get
there you cannot stop believing in any
way no matter what anybody says no
matter what anybody tells you you have
to know it beyond knowing it and it is a
it is a feeling when something is for
you this is our newest for me when
something's for you there's a feeling
that it's deep down inside of you that
will not allow you to let it go you have
it will it will keep you going when you
can't even keep yourself going that's
why the mantra here at the typewriter
studios is no place where even dreams
believe because there comes a time in
your life where you've worked and
stressed and you try to get there and
you couldn't on your own but you have a
dream and that dream has to take on the
belief for you because you can't do it
by yourself so what I would tell you is
this don't stop
narrow your focus to one idea one and
make it work that will give birth to all
the others all you can do is plant the
seed and water it a lot of people stop
too soon a lot of people quit too early
they do it because it's the logical
thing to do it's the rational thing to
do it's a smart thing to do because you
have this voice inside of your head that
says you can't do this why you keep
going right you have friends around you
the little man whether you're your own
little man or the people around you or
who tell you all the reasons why
something's not gonna work out and then
you stop and you quit and you give up
and you go do the thing that everybody
else does that's not an entrepreneur an
entrepreneur is a person that doesn't
stop that doesn't quit that doesn't give
in because this is the thing they have
to wrap your head around you have to put
a disproportionate amount of time energy
love resources into your idea before
will ever pay you back you have to put
more energy and time into something then
is logical then is reasonable that makes
sense because that's the only
you create something from nothing and
it's hard to continue to put time and
energy and resources and there's
something that's not happy to pay off
because your logical brain and the
friends around you tell you why are you
doing this what are you gonna stop are
you crazy and you have to be a little
bit crazy you have to be crazy in love
with the idea that you're doing to the
point where it defies logic it defies
reason because you feel it here and the
real entrepreneurs are the people who
will find ways to make it happen you may
be limited in your resources but you're
not limited in your resourcefulness you
find a different way to make it happen
even if that means taking on part-time
jobs two or three other jobs to pay the
bills so that you can't keep going
because eventually you know that it's
gonna work out and if you find that
thing that makes you come alive then you
have to hold on to it you have to keep
going because it may never come again
this could be your one shot and you
don't want to live the rest of your life
and regret wondering what could have
happened if you actually had the courage
to not stop so don't quit and believe so
the question is a today is I want to
know when you feel like stopping when
you feel like quitting share in the
comments below
and hopefully by sharing it you'll
release a little bit of it and you can
also get the support and wisdom and
ideas from the other fellow belief
nation community so leaving them
comments below I'm going to join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot event special
Oh give me go